these violent vegetarians
that's what they are
not calling the shots
this app has been such a game changer to
me I've never been so consistent with my
Quran reading before I knew about qurani
and you can get quranly absolutely free
no credit cards for seven day free trial
okay
let's get measured so you can tell us
what's going on the ground here because
it's going to start raining in a second
is he here okay let me call it all right
let's go let's go in the middle let's go
should we go in the middle
let's go let's go okay let's go let's go
attempt sometimes
[Applause]
[Applause]
foreign
all right guys listen carefully
listen carefully listen carefully
guys guys guys guys guys
calm down there's a greater strategic
objective
yes you guys are up here hey guys
listen yeah
[ __ ]
foreign
the battle here is on many different
fronts there's a media battle there's an
intellectual battle there's a battle
that goes back all the way to India and
the Muslims there we need to we we want
now I understand that's what you want
what happened to one of them guys I'll
get you okay listen to me listen to me
how many how many how many lives
yeah let's put your guardian first
you want to speak to me
uh I'm a YouTuber
oh okay all right no problem no problem
yeah
can you give a speech about what
happened bro guys you have to understand
something yeah
what we have to understand is that this
is all well and good we're seeing
violence
in this country and that is inspired in
par on full by a fascistic ideology
which is has its Inspirations from the
same place as Adolf Hitler had his
Inspirations let me ask the question why
is it the case that we see this level of
extremism well that that isn't covered
by the Western media in is much the same
way as they would love to be able to
cover Muslims doing oppression to others
we're seeing silence complete silence on
the issue of hindutva
radicalization in and out of India see
now it's even coming to the United
Kingdom so the first thing we need to
understand
let me finish let me finish one
I understand
there's a battle going on and I agree
with you
I agree there's about going on here well
it's not just a battle of these
radicalists these violent vegetarians
that's what they are but we come
play to their tune quite frankly us
breaking cars or running here running
there that's not going to help us how's
that going to help us
tell me how I'm not going to say to you
don't defend yourself why were you two
weeks ago broth well you guys are going
to listen to your gangsters now where
were you two weeks ago when your people
were getting battered bruv where were
you well we're seeing on social media
your big gangsters now where were you
yeah yes okay it's okay thank you very
much for the people that love you as
well yeah yeah okay pilot one two people
get you you get them it's it's sad I'm
not blaming everybody but the thing is
my look look I've come I left my family
bro that's my family times you get it
yeah if I if I went I can I can yeah
yesterday there was a police Block in
Hindu now yeah helping the guys yeah the
police wash me as well one of my boys
will stop seven times in the back I had
a bully profession sounds all right yeah
you know Amazon Prime Time yeah
everything comes to you but fast food we
live like let me be honest bro we're
just potato countries and we'll stay on
the sofa okay I'm amazed a different
story I mean I didn't wake up let me let
me know okay in the Quran Allah says bro
Allah says 20 of you guys will deal with
steadfast about 200 of them what does
steadfast mean but it means you got big
biceps now don't get twisted I train
yeah but the point is this bro it's Iman
yeah you're coming again hype bro I'm
here I want to cover you know why
because we have a platform actually back
in the days it's BBC open BBC BBC tells
you whatever he wants here bro we have a
channel now we can put videos when we do
this thing about Zionism yeah bro the
national strategic Affairs in Israel
were buying ads on our Channel bro can
you imagine a country Israel fighting us
yeah so what I'm saying is we just want
to come and cover it I'm coming and he
goes ah humans are from London you're
coming here for clout
what are you on about I am actually here
for cloud you're right I want the cloud
so people can watch this and see what's
going on and what these people are doing
so the problem is actually when I step
here and we're infighting okay I left it
I said bro you talk I'm not here to talk
bro you think I've got nothing to do
coming into you I'm not a hero I'm not
hero bro if it comes to fight we will
fight bro okay I'm trying to say but I'm
saying brother there's a bigger picture
if you go there and attack the Hindu
temple one picture you're done Brothers
finished
if they came how many guys gonna stand
how many are you going to start and this
is physical this is
getting hyped and then forget that
you're fighting each other
if I was a Hindu one of these guys who
came to Allah I'll be laughing watching
it mashallah Define each other
I love it but I love every second of it
what I'm just saying is just
disappointed brother's coming to see you
from London
the proceeds from that charity we're
going to the police so when they marched
through Leicester yeah they March
through the Green Lane area where that
was clear incite yes that was clear
inside exactly now these guys don't know
any better yes now they see that their
their privileges are being yeah Paul can
you come here please capture this please
if you can come around local authorities
aren't doing anything about it yes
they're in coherence with the the police
yes when it comes down to the now we've
got no choice now you know what I'm on a
group yeah and on that group but then I
said listen brothers were you like
fighting why are you fighting because we
spoke amongst ourselves so what are you
doing what you need to do is you need to
turn around and take this to a political
and intellectual level exactly no no
they don't now at that political and
intellectual level it's corrupt so where
do you go of course the brothers are
going to take up arms well yesterday
there was a brother that turned around
and said uh when the brothers were doing
what's that we're gonna do are you crazy
this is the problem are you crazy this
is why you're here exactly
I don't care bro the easiest thing for
me to do is spark one of these guys in
the face yes this week this vegetarian
bro they can't fight yeah bro the
easiest thing for me to just punch them
but I know but I know bro but what I'm
saying is this year what I'm saying is
actually you can give them a bigger slap
you can give them a bigger Punch Yeah
I'm here because bro BBC's not gonna
cover it these look at them because can
we do an interview no look at them
casually no no no no simple we have a
platform I'm here to cover that come for
yourself okay you know what you know
what actually let me tell you something
assume the best thing assume the best if
I've come here okay look I leave my
family to come to Leicester to be like
yeah I'm the hero Ali that was coming to
save the day I'm gonna have to save
nobody I receive myself bro you don't
know
okay okay no problem no problem actually
write it down yourself okay I'm
indulging my own sins bro I'm drowning
my own sins okay I'm trying to save
myself let alone save anybody else but
the point I'm saying is I have a
platform if I can record this put it
there and put some pressure or let the
whole world of bigger world the the
world watch it at least we are doing
something because people are like okay
we're aware if a fire happens we're here
but we came here today if it happens
we're not going to stand in Bible
as simple as that but how long is your
successful I'm so sorry if you look for
a success in anywhere else you're gonna
fail you are going to fail it's as
simple as that bro I've just come here
for that and then a message to these
that are coming here uh this is not
India let's make it very clear don't
think you're gonna roll around what you
do in India and attack Muslims and um
God knows what else you do this is not
India yeah today you saw and believe
best believe best believe that this is
to us an intellectual war in that
context but if you come to us best
believe that we are not going to be
watching you attack children kids Etc
and this is deeply rooted with hindutra
these thought of these fogs yeah these
little terrorist scum Fox here and they
are coming here and trying to provoke
the communities the Hindus and the
Muslims have been living here for a long
time in peace yeah no problem exactly so
just to reiterate this is not India and
um you will find out it's not India if
you carry on like this yeah what
happened how did it all start basically
for the past since everything kicked off
down here
um the the people the troublemakers were
going around attacking people they're
from the Hindu Community they went into
hiding so since then everything's been
peaceful no drama is nothing police
assured us that listen we've got
everything unlocked we've got extra
police out here we've got senior police
officers looking into this you'll not
just keep the community calm from your
side and we've got everything sorted
from our side out of the blue yesterday
around six o'clock messages were going
around there's over two three hundred
Hindu thugs wearing palatlavas masks
hoodies with weapons walking down the
street chanting stuff and go walking
past the mustard and then they went to
they were travel they traveled over two
and a half miles yeah for that long the
the police let them continue marching
towards the Greenland Road area they
could have stopped them way before that
exactly yeah they let them go all the
way to the ending and that's when they
started attacking people on the streets
random Muslims on the streets were
getting attacked and when they local
Muslims the video started going around
that's when everybody started coming out
and they said you know what police can't
look after the community then got
control of the situation like they said
they have we need to go out confront
these people because up until then they
were in hiding yeah so they said that
now that they've come out we need to
confront these people and we need to
protect our own Community if this was
Muslims yeah and for from what we know
these courses are even connected they
have traces back to a a Hindu temple Etc
yeah and nobody's asking to go and
attack any place of worship the point
I'm trying to say is just imagine a
Muslim Masjid in Reading imagine
emergency I'm not gonna give a name a a
mission in London and a coach connected
to there
Isis boss they say the Isis bus arrived
here attacking
um the Hindus and all kind of nonsense
would have happened but you can and they
came and they came with they came with
weapons yeah this is this was organized
okay the brothers in front of the police
were saying look at them they've got
weapons in front of them broad daylight
yeah on camera yes look at them they've
got weapons the police had no control
over the situation
exactly so what we're going to do is
we're just going to wrap up inshallah
you'll see more videos inshallah about
what happened and how this is connected
to Hindi for BJP group in India